Former NBA star Dennis Rodman left Pyongyang Friday,...
...singing the praises of North Korean leader Kim Jong-Un.
He's proud.
His country likes him. Not likes him, love him.
Love him and guess what?
Yes, yes, I love him.
I love, the guy's awesome.
In an unexpected round of basketball diplomacy,...
...Rodman spent time with Kim during his visit to North Korea this week.
Together, they watched the Harlem Globetrotters play and ate sushi.
They mostly do one thing. You know what, it was at least how they were so honest.
And then one thing that, guess what? His grandfather and his father were great leaders.
He's such a proud man.
The basketball star is the most high profile American to meet Kim...
...since he took power back in December 2011.
He arrived Monday with a television crew and three members of the Harlem Globetrotters.
The meeting took place amidst high tension between Washington and Pyongyang,...
...following the communist nation's underground nuclear test two weeks ago.
Matt Small, The Associated Press.